if you're an entrepreneur you can't quit
you can't throw in the towel it's going
to be tough it's going to be one of the
hardest things you've ever done in your
life you're going to doubt yourself
you're going to wonder why you don't go
back and get a job but you can't quit
because starting the business takes time
even if you model success even view the
smartest person in the world it still
takes time and you need to make sure
that you're around when that success
comes something you do right now may
take a year before it comes back and
that momentum gross I need to make sure
you're still here you can't quit Milton
Hershey who started the Hershey
Chocolate Company he started his
business when he was 18 years old
Philadelphia he bought a hundred dollars
from his n because he had no money to
start up and he started in caramels and
he worked 15 16 hours a day he'd make
the caramels at night and then he'd sell
them on the streets during the day the
business in philly failed so i moved to
chicago and that the same thing not
failed moved to New Orleans into the
same thing and not fail the new to New
York tried it up again and one day he
got robbed on the streets in New York he
lost all his inventory he had to close
down the business and return home to
Philadelphia he had spent six years
building these businesses in different
states and they all failed he came back
home to his family and they disowned him
they said your failure you're not part
of our family anymore you're not meant
to be an entrepreneur and so the only
place he could stay was at the house of
one of his former employees Henry and
Henry gave him a place to staying a
little bit of money to keep going cuz
Milton Hershey had a new idea for
business he went to get in the
chocolates people said he was crazy like
her she this isn't for you you're not
meant to be an entrepreneur you've
worked 15 16 hours a day for six years
and you just had for failures go do
something else go get a job but he
couldn't do it he couldn't quit he knew
it was in his blood he had to go after
it chocolate the time was only for the
rich people and he discovered a machine
that could make it affordable for
everybody to do in to consume so he
started chocolate and the rest is
history he stuck around so he could
achieve his success even when people
didn't believe in him even when he had
failure after failure after failure he
lost everything he lost his family but
he kept going you didn't quit I know
it's tough I know it's hard as an
entrepreneur you may doubt yourself
every day wonder if you should stop but
just when the times are toughest when
its darkest around you you have to go
one more day you can't quit if you're
following your passion and you're
helping people you can't quit the light
is around the tunnel it's there I
promise you if you can't see it now it's
there and you have to take that one more
step go one more day so you can achieve
it good luck